my name is darren cannelly i work for
berkey's farm store i've been a
precision farming specialist for about
seven years now
and uh the interesting part about
telematics is we do have a segment of
the industry that is more interested in
telematics especially your larger
operations your fertilizer dealers your
co-ops who are interested in fleet
management most of our producers
customers that don't have a large volume
of equipment are not so interested in
telematics now but i think the point at
which they will become interesting when
we start to really push in
the reduced downtime during the off
season
i think where that really comes into
play is off-site diagnostics so if a guy
goes down if he's able to make a
telephone call and somebody that's miles
away can access that monitor and try to
find out what the problem is that he can
keep going sooner i think that's where a
lot of guys are going to see the value
in telematics at this point
we don't really see that value as much
or the customers haven't even realized
that but i think as time goes on they're
going to start realizing the value of
that piece of the puzzle more than just
a fleet management like a lot of
customers or co-ops are seeing now
i think just selling the value i think a
lot of guys now when they think of
telematics they think that they'll be
able to download their information from
their tractor to their home
wirelessly and they're interested in
that but yeah they don't see a great
value in that because they can take
their card or transfer it in many other
ways so they don't see a great value in
that and i don't think a lot of them
have really seen that value that can
come from reduced down time so i think
from a dealership perspective we need to
be selling that value in order to see
to be able to have them convinced of
what that value could bring to them and
telematics
i think where we're seeing right now is
some of the more productive producers
more some of the more advanced producers
are starting to be interested in this
and they will be the early adopters
we'll probably jump into and i always
say the proof is in the pudding and so
when you get more and more people that
are starting to do this they're going to
see the value themselves and they're
going to start promoting it to the the
different friends and the neighbor
farmers that they do have and then from
a dealer perspective if we continue to
push that
it'll continue to grow